hello my name is glenn lowery
i'm the merton stoltz professor of the
social sciences at brown university and
professor of economics there and i've
been writing for many years about the
issues of race and inequality in the
united states
i'm here to talk about race in america
with particular emphasis on the black
family i just want to share with you
some thoughts that i prepared for this
occasion
um i want to talk about the fact of
historical
african-american subordination i want to
say
what it means for american citizenship
and i want to consider
some possible solutions to this
long-standing dilemma
the priority of social relations before
economic transactions
is my theme but don't worry i'll not be
masquerading as a sociologist or a
political theorist rather i'm going to
draw in my many years of study as an
economist
and a public intellectual to briefly
make two
observations and then draw some
conclusions one about the dynamics of
human development
and the other about the foundations of
racial identity
i will bring this back to the theme of
the black family in conclusion
now why i ask the success of the civil
rights movement notwithstanding
has the subordinate status of african
americans persisted
in the 21st century clear thinking about
this intractable problem requires one to
distinguish the role played by
discrimination against black people
from the role of counterproductive
patterns of behavior that can be found
within african-american society now i
admit that this puts what is a very
sensitive issue
rather starkly many vocal advocates of
racial ineq
of racial equality refuse even to
consider the possibility that
problematic behavior could be an
important factor
contributing to the persisting
disadvantage of blacks
at the same time some observers on the
right of american politics
insist that anti-black discrimination is
no longer an important determinant of
unequal social outcomes i've tried to
chart a middle course acknowledging
anti-black biases that should be
remedied
but insisting on the imperative of
addressing and reversing
the behavior patterns preventing some
blacks from seizing newly
opened opportunities among these
behavior patterns are going to be the
interactions between men and women
within the context of family formation
child bearing and child rearing this is
an explosive topic in american political
culture
i can remember within my own lifetime
when daniel patrick moynihan's report
was first issued in that in 1965
the negro family the case for national
action he called it
he argued then with 25 percent of black
children being born to a woman without a
husband that this problem was going to
stand as a fundamental barrier to black
progress
and indeed if it weren't somehow dealt
with might prevent the fruit of the
civil rights movement's successes
from being enjoyed fully by african
americans and by the country
he was pilloried for daring to raise the
question
as a white man and since then
a political discussion about this
question has been
stifled and truncated people have been
we're
wary to raise the issues and to talk
about these
these themes they don't want to be
accused of blaming the victim
they don't want to seem to be judgmental
they don't want to be imposing a
moral calculus on
the lives of people especially of people
who have been victimized by
discrimination
and who may be plagued by poverty this i
think is a mistake
what was 25 when moynihan was
calling his call to arms was issuing his
call to arms over a half century ago
is 70 percent now the african-american
family one could say is in deep
trouble again there will be pushback
people will say why do you judge family
by a single norm
they will say it takes a village to
raise a child why should we think in
terms of patrimony
patriarchy i should say and in terms of
the nuclear family is the only model
i don't want to waste my time with those
arguments i simply want to call
attention to the needs of young people
that have stable
social foundations within the context of
which they can mature
and realize their human potential and i
want to say that a mother and father
raising children is a sounder foundation
to that end then as a mother raising
those children alone
i'll have more to say about that in due
course but let me return to
the framework that i want to try to
elaborate for you by discussing
those two observations these two
positions can be recast as
causal narratives one i'm going to call
the bias narrative
racism and white supremacy have done us
wrong we can't get ahead
until they relent so we must continue
urging reform on american society toward
that end
the other narrative i'm going to call
the development narrative
emphasizing the need to consider how
people come to acquire
those skills traits habits and
orientations
that foster an individual's successful
participation
in american society to the extent that
black youngsters do not have the
experiences
are not exposed to the influences and do
not benefit from the resources
that foster and facilitate their human
development to that extent
they may fail to achieve their full
potential
it is this lack of development that
ultimately causes the stark racial
disparities in income
wealth education and much else to
persist
so goes the development narrative so we
have two narratives
the bias narrative and the development
narrative
we have two basic approaches to the
problem of persisting racial inequality
to assume that it's the consequence of
discrimination
or to understand it at least in part as
the result of the failure
of many african americans to realize
their full human potential
i want to emphasize this latter
narrative as being more relevant to our
present day
and i want to call attention to the role
of the family
as a part of the larger developmental
matrix which either fosters or impedes
the
potential for achievement for black
people
in america
these two narratives of course need not
be mutually exclusive
but in terms of prescribing
interventions and remedies they point in
very different directions the bias
narrative urges us to
well to have a conversation about race
white america must reform itself
racism must end we need more of this or
more of that whatever
this or that is on the agenda of today's
social justice warriors
one can hear this kind of talk and read
these exhortations and newspapers
and other media daily
the development narrative alternatively
puts more onus on the responsibilities
of african americans to develop our
human potential
not on our own to be sure not without
the support in the assistance of
whatever social programs the society
should decide
are justified but nevertheless
ultimately
the responsibility for raising one's
children into maturity
rest on the parents of those children
first
and foremost the development narrative
is not satisfied with
wishful thinking like if we could only
double the budget for some social
program then the homicide rate among
young black men would
be less atrocious or if we could just
get the local police department
investigated by the u.s department of
justice then
then what the development narrative
wants to ask
then it'll become possible to walk on
the south side of chicago after midnight
i am one social scientist who finds that
to be an extremely
dubious claim so
what are my two observations
over four decades ago in my doctoral
dissertation at mit i had the good
fortune to coin the term
social capital i did so by way of
contrasting my concept social capital
with what economists then traditionally
called
human capital as you may know human
capital theory
imports into the study of human
inequality
an intellectual framework which had been
developed primarily
to explain investment decisions by firms
a framework that focuses on the analysis
of formal economic transactions
in my thesis i argued that this
framework was inadequate to the problem
of accounting
for social inequality please allow me to
explain
my fundamental point was that
associating business and human
investments
is merely an analogy not an identity
particularly if one seeks to explain
persistent racial disparities
business investments are transactional
human investments are essentially
relational
so important things are overlooked in
the human capital approach
things having to do with informal social
relations
such as those which occur inside of
families
human capital theory is incomplete when
it comes to explaining racial
disparities i argued
there are two central aspects of this
incompleteness and thus my two
observations about the dynamics of human
development
and the nature of racial identity permit
me to explain
first i stress that all human
development is socially situated
and mediated that is i argue that the
development of human beings occurs
inside of social institutions it takes
place as between people
by way of human interactions the family
the community
the school the peer group these cultural
institutions of human association are
where development is achieved
resources essential to human development
the attention that a parent gives to her
child for instance
are not alienable developmental
resources for the most part are not
commodities
the development of human beings is
largely not up for sale
rather structured connections between
individuals create the context within
which developmental resources
come to be allocated to individual
persons i ask you to forgive me
i speak like an economist i talk about
resources and i talk about allocation
i can't help myself i am an economist
but bear with
me because these categories are i think
useful as a conceptual framework
for talking about the problem of
inequality which is what i am
intending to talk about here today
opportunity
travels along the synapses of social
networks
the development of human beings is not
the same as corporate investment and so
it need not be a good metaphor or a good
analogy to reason as though this were so
people are not machines their
productivities
that is to say the behavioral and
cognitive capacities
bearing on their social and economic
function these things are not merely the
result of a mechanical
infusion of material resources
redistributing money doesn't necessarily
fix the problem
when these things are in deficit
rather the capacities to develop human
beings are the byproducts of social
processes that are mediated
by networks of human affiliation and
connectivity
this was fundamentally important i
thought and still think
for understanding persistent racial
disparities in america and that's why i
coined the term social capital in order
to emphasize
the difference between the benefits to
human development that flow
from social connectivity and those
benefits that flow from monetary
resources
that's the first point that i wanted to
make all those years ago
about the incompleteness of human
capital theory
now my second observation
was that what we are calling race in
america
is mainly a social and only indirectly a
biological phenomenon
mind you now i'm talking about racial
inequality in america and the black
family
so i'm talking about inequality and i'm
talking about race
my first observation was an observation
about inequality
inequality in human development because
of the way that social networks
either do or do not deliver the
relations that are necessary in order
for people
to flourish and reach their potential
now i want to talk about race and in
america
that is not only but it is substantially
in our history a matter of black
and white and so as i go forward i will
talk about race in
somewhat binary terms which is not
entirely descriptive
of the complex demographic landscape
that we inhabit here in the 21st century
in the united states of america
but which should be a useful starting
point for thinking about the problem of
racial inequality and persisting black
disadvantage
which is the subject of this lecture so
my second observation
was that what we are calling race in
america is mainly a social and only
indirectly a biological phenomenon
the persistence across generations of
racial differentiation between large
groups of people
in an open society where individuals
live
in close proximity to one another
provides irrefutable indirect evidence
of a profound separation between the
racially defined social
networks of affiliation within that
society
that was a somewhat complicated sentence
so let me try to put it more directly
there would be no races in the study
state of any dynamic social system
unless
on a daily basis and in regard to their
most intimate affairs
people paid very close attention to the
boundaries
that separate themselves from racially
distinct
others
over time that is race
in inverted commas would cease to exist
unless people chose to act in a manner
so as biologically to reproduce
the variety of phenotypic expression
that constitutes the subject subject of
racial distinction
again a complex sentence packed with
ideas that are important to the subject
of our discussion here right now
i can't overemphasize the point i'm
trying to make at this moment
what we're calling race is not something
that is given in nature
rather it is a social product it's an
equilibrium outcome it's something that
we collectively within the society are
making
and remaking over time it is as we
economists like to say
an endogenous outcome
it follows that if the goal is to
understand the roots of durable racial
inequality
one needs to attend in some detail to
the processes that cause
race to persist as a fact in the society
under study because those processes
almost certainly will not be unrelated
to the allocation of developmental
resources
in that society again i need to
apologize for being an economist i'm
talking about the allocation of
developmental resources
my first point was that that depends on
how people are located
relative to each other within social
networks it depends upon relations
but i'm also talking about racial
inequality and my second observation is
that depends
on how people in that society behave in
terms of their most intimate
social relations with one another
because without mating patterns that are
largely
within racial groups the very fact of
distinct races within the society
would fade away and wither away over
time
so those are the two observations that i
want to make as a foundation for
carrying forward my argument
about the black family here then is my
second observation in a nutshell
the creation and reproduction of race as
a social reality in any society
rests on cultural conceptions about
identity
that are embraced by people blacks and
whites alike
in that society these are the
convictions
people affirm about who they are and
about the legitimacy of conducting
intimate relations
with racially distinct others and here i
do not only mean
sexual relations my impulse to contrast
human and social capital all those years
ago was rooted
in my conviction that beliefs of this
kind ultimately determine the access
that people enjoy to the informal
resources required to develop their
human potential
what i called social capital in 1976
was on this view a critical prerequisite
for creating what economists
typically refer to as human capital this
point again
is crucial if we're to understand the
persistence of racial inequality in
america
but what you're going to ask yourselves
is this to do with the black family well
perhaps
perhaps that connection is becoming
clear because the black family is the
context within which african americans
are situated especially in the earliest
years of life
and where these dynamics of human
development are playing out
for better or for ill
historically oppressed groups time and
again have evolved notions of identity
that cut against the grain of their
society's mainstream
a culture can develop among them that
inhibits talented youngsters from taking
the actions
needed to develop their talent now given
such a situation
i want to ask do the kids in
dysfunctional peer groups
or from families that are poorly
structured simply have the wrong utility
functions or do those communities simply
have the wrong values
now i want to hold that it's a mistake
to attribute the dysfunctional behavior
of a historically oppressed group
to their simply having the wrong
preferences when those preferences have
emerged from a set of historical
experiences that reflect the larger
society's structures
and activities it's a mistake to simply
blame the victim
on the other hand it's also a mistake to
ignore patterns of behavior within
population groups
that may inhibit their ability to take
full advantage
of the opportunities that are present in
their society
you can make a mistake in blaming the
victim and you can make a mistake in
looking away from the role that the
victim quote unquote
might play in his or her own bad
situation
another way of saying this is that
social relations
come before economic transactions
when ethnic communities and their local
cultures are not integrated across
boundaries of race in a society
then racial inequality can persist
notwithstanding the enactment
and effective enforcement of laws
against discrimination
the persistence of racial disparities
derives not simply from discrimination
but more fundamentally
from the complex morally ambiguous and
difficult to regulate phenomena
that embody and reflect what people see
as the meanings
giving significance to their lives and
from the structure of the social
connectivity
to which those meanings give rise all
this
leads me to an important uh conclusion
namely how a diverse society answers the
question who are we
is a fundamentally significant issue
who are we whose country is it
when we talk about crime violence school
failure urban decay
or family life for that matter are these
matters in the back of our mind that we
understand as
us and them because if it's
us against them anything is possible it
becomes possible for example to say
about those people languishing in the
ghettos of our great cities
that's not my country that's not me
those aren't my people
that's some third world thing or
whatever
i mention this because we're talking
about family life we're talking about
intimate personal relations i'm arguing
that inequality to some degree is the
consequence
of a failure or a dysfunction in the
family lives
of black people i'm a black person
myself i don't take any pleasure
in making this argument i feel compelled
to make it
but in doing so i don't want to join a
chorus of critics who stand on the
outside and point fingers
at those people and talk about their
deficiencies
i don't want to be a hypocritical
moralist who wags my finger
in their faces and tell them that they
should live quote better
close quote but i do want to be a
realist i don't want to look away from
the consequences of the way in which
many of them are
as a matter of fact living in doing so
however i don't want to give license to
those who want to
wipe their hands of the matter turn
their backs on these people
who need our help and simply go on about
their business
and so that's why i asked the question
who are we here
in america my point is that these
problems including the problems of
african-american family life are
quintessentially an american affair
not simply an amer a measure of the
inadequacy
of black culture they reflect upon
our social inadequacy i wish to argue
and by our i mean all of us
for example much of the decline in
uh the structure of the african-american
family i say decline because i mean the
rise of out of wedlock birth and the
decline in the prevalence of husband
wife households
much of that decline i think can be laid
at the feet
of the consequences of american welfare
policy which has created incentives
uh for family dissolution much of it i
think could be laid at the feet of
drifts in american culture
in which the virtues of of monogamous
and
husband-wife families has declined
amongst all groups
reflected in the popular media and so
forth black people in the united states
are not on an
island they live integrated within the
largest social fabric
and so patterns of behavior that we see
among them are not simply
on them they are also to some degree
on us this is what i mean when
being an economist i nevertheless insist
on placing relations before
transactions what i'm talking about now
in other words is the american
story not just the black american story
let me conclude consider the poor
central city dwellers who now make up
maybe a quarter of the
black american population the
dysfunctional behavior of many in this
uh population is a big part of the
problem here
so conservatives demand for greater
personal responsibility in these
quarters is necessary
and proper and yet confronted with the
despair
violence and self-destructive folly of
so many people
is it moral it is morally and
intellectually superficial
in the extreme to argue as many have
done
that those people should just get their
acts together
like many of the poor immigrants if they
did we wouldn't have such a horrific
problem in our cities
to the contrary i would say any morally
astute response to the social pathology
of american history's losers should
conclude that while we cannot change our
ignoble past
we need not and must not be indifferent
to the contemporary consequences of
it their culture
may be implicated in their difficulties
but then so too is our culture
complicit in their troubles we and i
mean all americans bear collective
responsibility
for the form and the texture of our
society's social relations
and racial discrimination and racial
segregation is a part of that structure
in texture it is also a part of the
foundation
for racial inequality in the country i
am not talking here out of both sides of
my mouth
i insist on recognizing the importance
of the family
acknowledging the decline of structure
of family amongst african americans
and owning the consequences of that
decline in terms of its contribution to
racial inequality
but i'm also not a moral infant
i know that having recognized those
social connections and the role that
they play in persisting inequality
i have not solved the problem of what is
the right thing to do for the society as
a whole
we need to support stronger
african-american families
we need to provide the kind of support
that people need
in order to be able to do their duty and
do their and
fulfill their responsibilities in
raising their children but we need also
to insist without equivocation
that responsible parenting is the
foundation
for prosperity in any society including
in this one
and that responsible african-american
parenting
is an absolute essential prerequisite
for narrowing and ultimately eliminating
the racial inequality gap in america
thank you